b
hello everyone and welcome to our quiz
today on the general programming
concepts
we would request you to bear with us as
we wait a few minutes for people to join
the stream feel free to introduce
yourself in the comments section while
we wait
also to take part in the quiz it is
highly recommended to use your mobile
phone to visit the website www.menti.com
and use the code
1 61173331 code is visible on the live
stream
you can use a different tab on your
browser to take part in the quiz but a
live stream will be broadcasting the
results as soon as the participants give
the answers so it is beneficial to have
both screens visible at the same time
once you open the link and input the
code wait for the quiz to start and be
ready to answer the questions the
quicker you answer the more points you
get so think fast and click faster
just going to wait for a few more
minutes to let other people join
okay so while we wait for other people
to join
allow me to introduce our viewers to the
world of programming
the software development has grown much
and shown more impact on our day-to-day
life all the knowledge on development
comes from coding and programming so we
bring you some tips to learn and get
experience in coding without going
through any kind of hardship
first we shall begin and understand what
the exact meaning of coding is followed
by what is the meaning of programming
then we get in touch with learning the
differences between coding and
programming
after that we shall discuss some tips
for learning these skills
so let's get started with what coding is
the computer doesn't understand the
human language so we use some languages
that require coding to communicate with
the computer it is a way of passing and
translating the instructions to
communicate with our systems
this is about coding but what about
programming
programming is the process of designing
and building executable programs to work
on specific tasks that involve the
analysis generation and implementation
of algorithms
many of the applications and development
involves end users programming from the
top to the end
this is all about programming
now let's get started by learning some
differences between coding and
programming
coding is a part of programming which is
used to help in converting the language
into binary codes which can then be used
to communicate with the computer
whereas programming is a process that
works on creating specific tasks
according to the standard set
the next difference is that coding is
the basic step in implementing the
software whereas programming deals with
implementation depth and complex
problems
coding works with simple projects that
can be finished in a shorter period
whereas programming deals with big
projects and processes complete analysis
to implement this project
so these are some fundamental
differences between coding and
programming
now let's look at some of the best tips
for learning the art of coding
the first step that we have for you is
practice
practice is the best way to learn coding
and programming it takes a lot of time
to develop it into a habit but helps
gain more knowledge along the way when
you apply for a software job there will
most likely be a technical round where
they ask you to write snippets of codes
practicing helps to clear those rounds
and get an opportunity to clear them
quite quickly it also improves the
ability to identify the mistake by
yourself
our next step is consistency in reading
the main problem in learning is
consistency
while we work in our free time it does
not help much because of the power of
our brain
working daily helps to gain and boost
our knowledge which then further helps
us to think logically and improve our
skills so we have to work every day to
learn how to program
the next step of the session is deep
learning
when you get deeply involved in the
subject you are learning it provides a
way to gain more knowledge and attention
to the subject
the deeper effort we put the more we get
back it also helps us in improving our
thinking skills it boosts the
performance while carrying out the
simplest of tasks
the next step of the dock is jumping
directly if you are going to learn
something you must start from the
beginning it helps to predict and
provide a complete understanding of the
upcoming topics in the subject
if you are learning coding or
programming you better start from the
basics it helps you grab the subject's
attention and improve your coding and
programming knowledge
moving forward the next topic we have is
debugging
making mistakes in code and programming
is very common
there are key producers of learning so
it is good to use debugging to improve
your coding and programming skills if
you are good at debugging you will learn
quite quickly without any hassle
another resource that we have in our
disposal is online resources
one of the accessible sources of
learning coding and programming are
multiple websites and blogs
there are plenty of online resources
like simplylearn that provide and help a
lot in learning a new skill they also
offer free courses and videos with the
most trending concepts on the market
and most importantly the final tip of
the session is representation
representing the concept you learn plays
a crucial part in learning it may help
get more ideas and think more profoundly
about the subject teaching to someone
discussing and sharing will help get
more command over coding and program so
it's a good idea to represent everything
that you have learned
so far that's all we need to know about
the tips on coding and programming
we can start with the quiz
just a reminder to join the quiz please
visit the website
www.mente.com and use the code
61173331 to participate
like i mentioned before do try to join
the quiz using the mobile phone to keep
your eyes on the results of the quiz as
it progresses on the live stream this
will help you stay in touch with the
standings since the top three winners
will receive amazon vouchers faster
answers equal higher points so fire away
as soon as you have a hunch
we're going to wait for a couple of more
people to join the quiz before we start
just a reminder guys it is recommended
to join using a mobile phone although
you can join using your
laptop browser or a different tab as
well
kulsham the top three scorers will be
eligible for the prizes so if you answer
quickly you can be a part of the top 3
winners who will receive amazon vouchers
from rn
so make sure to answer fast
just going to wait for one more minute
the quiz will have 30 questions in total
so in total you can expect around 40-45
minutes
okay so it seems we have enough people
to start the quiz for now
okay let's move on to our first
remember guys faster answers means
faster points
question one is which of the following
components in java is responsible for
complete code debugging compilation and
execution
is it the option a jre
is it option b jdk
is it c jv m
or d jit
please see the question carefully and
check which particular programming
language we are referring to which of
the following components in java is
responsible for complete end-to-end
execution of our program
okay times are up
it's in majority of people had answered
jvm
but the correct answer is jdk
okay so before deciding on the answer
let's learn about each of these terms
that we have mentioned right now the jre
is abbreviated as a java runtime
environment it creates the executable
java application and provides the
necessary program execution environment
for the code
jvm is abbreviated as java virtual
machine it enables a computer to run
java programs and the programs written
in other languages compiled to java
bytecode
jdk is known as the java development kit
it is the combined java runtime
environment and java virtual machine
package
so both jvm and gre are needed to
execute a program in java that's why the
correct answer is jdk
the last of which is jit which nobody
answered
is known as the just-in-time compiler it
is an inventory management method in
which goods are received from suppliers
only as they are needed
remember guys like we told you
the faster you answer the questions
the higher points you will get
okay it seems two people answered very
quickly
and many of them are not able to so
let's move on and see how the
leaderboard changes with the next set of
questions moving on to question number
two
which set class in java should be most
popular in a multi-threading environment
considering performance constraints
is the option a hash set
is the b concurrent skip list set is its
c linked hash set or copy on write error
set
go to the options very carefully
considering there is a bit of
allotration involved
five more seconds
okay the answers are pretty distributed
in this one but the correct answer is
actually option b which is concurrent
skip list set
so the concurrent skip list class allows
safe execution of insertion removal and
access operations on set concurrently by
multiple threads
so in other words only one thread can
access the set at a time which degrades
the performance
concurrent skip list set implement
serialize cloneable iterable collection
navigable set set and sorted set
interfaces it does not allow null
elements because null arguments return
values which cannot be reliably
distinguished
its implementation provides an average
log and time cost for containing adding
and removing operations and the variance
and also it is thread safe
it should be preferred over implementing
the set interface when concurrent
modification of the set is required
okay we see not a lot of people are able
to answer which propels skywalker to
first position and akshay to second
okay we're going to see some new people
in the leaderboard in the first few set
of questions
okay moving on to question number three
which of the following collections in
java will allow the removal of elements
from a collection
is it option a enum
is it option b iterator
is it c list
or d none of the above
which of them will allow the removal of
elements from a collection
i'm guessing a lot of people will be
missing
a common term in java which is not in
the options
okay everyone has voted
and pretty equal distribution for the
answers again but the correct answer is
list not enum iterator but list the
answer is a list because all of the
above listed options or collections are
immutable
the enum or enumerators in java are
tightly immutable so it makes sense that
the inner must return a clone of the
array returned by the values method each
time the method is called to ensure that
the array is associated with the enum
has not been changed for added safety
so next are the iterators the output or
the collection of elements retired from
a method during multi-threading is
strongly immutable because of the
iterators hence there is no chance here
as well
so lastly the list error list collection
is mutable that allows for the addition
or removal of elements so just not
removal even the addition of elements is
possible
okay the top two scorers are not able to
answer it correctly so we have a new
leader on the top
okay let's move on to question number
four
it is a long quiz guys so make sure take
every chance you do get
question four which of these in java is
not an access modifier
is it a private
b void
c public or d protected
i just like to reiterate guys if you
want to join the quiz please go to
www.menti.com
and use the code
61173331 to take part
any answers submitted in the youtube
comments will not be able to take part
then more seconds
which are the the following in java is
not an access modifier
okay we see majority of people were able
to answer this correctly and the answer
is void the void might seem like a
default access modifier but it is not
we have public private and protected
access modifiers if no access modifier
is declared then by default java will
consider public access modifier to be
used now this will differ from language
to language but when as far as java is
concerned void is not an access modifier
irrespective of you provide one in the
code or not
okay so a lot of people in the lower end
of the leaderboard have moved up
and the leader is nuts has already
create a healthy lead at the first
position okay so let's move on to
question five
what will be the output of the following
code segment
you have one minute to answer
guys just to be sure this is no uh
there's not a quiz regarding any
particular programming language so this
is just users programming launching oops
concepts and all those things so
irrespective of you work with java or
python or c plus plus you can't take
part in this quiz and remember guys the
top three winners get amazon vouchers so
give it a try so what what the shot
20 more seconds
you see 19 people have already answered
which leaves out a couple of people who
have not yet decided on the output
okay so nine people were able to give
the correct answer which is 30.
okay now most of you must have thought
the answer would be 25 but if we recall
our programming fundamentals we'll come
across the precedence table so the
precedence table will help us understand
the priority of each mathematical and
logical symbol that we use on our
day-to-day programming
according to this presidency table
pre-increment has a higher priority than
the multiplication operator so the
number 5 has pre-incremented to the
number 6 and 6 multiplied by 5
results in 30.
it was a bit confusing but
more or less it makes sense that a lot
of people were able to answer correctly
okay so we do not see any change in the
top two leaderboard but we do see a
healthy shuffle
from three to ten
okay we're expecting some new names
in these top 10 leaderboards let's see
question number six is whatsapp
concurrent model is implemented using
which programming language
is it a java would it be nodejs
is it c erlang or d c
i'm expecting people are aware of all
these programming languages
five more seconds
okay a tie between java and erlang with
the correct answer being
earlier see whatsapp which has like
billions of messages sent over its
platform every day has been built with
the free bsd operating system and the
erlang programming language
okay only two people were able to give
the correct answer the top position in
the leaderboard and the tenth one
again mole is slowly catching up at the
sixth position okay let's see if the
next question will have a healthy number
of correct answers this time
question number seven is predict the
outcome of the following program in c
i'm assuming a lot of the people who
have worked on c plus plus will be able
to answer this question as well
considering how closely related they are
they have 45 seconds
as it's clear from the code you have to
find the output of the strlen function
and the sizeof function
5 9 720 520 or 820 are your options
this is a little tricky question i'll
give you that
five more seconds
okay majority were able to answer
correctly which is eight people answered
the options are a which is five and nine
so the question might have been a little
tricky but it revolves around simple
data structure oriented information
so we all know the terminating character
in strings so the length of the string
is the count of characters up to a null
character which is often denoted by a
backslash zero
so the answer of the strlen method
describes the length as 5
and the size of method reports the size
of the array as 9.
might be able to see a shuffle yes we do
we have a new name at the second
position which is nithya ram
welcome to the top three nithya ram
let's see how long you can hold your
position
in the
top of the leaderboard okay let's move
on to question number eight
which of the following operator is used
to extract pattern matching data from
the database
is it a fine
is it b select
is it c like
or the pattern
start thinking the last time you recall
sql
just a couple of more people to answer i
can say 18 people have already answered
this
okay eight people were able to give the
correct answer which is option c like
okay sql is a very powerful data
querying language most of the time you
might extract the data according to your
logic
but in a few scenarios you might have to
check if your required output matches a
given pattern for example try selecting
the cell or row where a color code is
given a color code can be pqrs and
slower case or pqrs in upper case so you
can use the like operator design
exclusively for pattern matching in sql
in such scenarios
also like is case sensitive
as an alternative you can always use i
like if you have the pattern in both the
upper and the lower cases together
as expected majority were able to answer
correctly which i think will push
nithyaran down to third and anmol was
the fastest one to answer getting the
highest points for this question and
moving up to the second position okay
let's move on to question number nine
python includes built in which libraries
is it a css
b json
3 php or for html
by the guys i see a lot of new people
have joined the youtube stream so i'd
like to inform you that if you want to
take part in the quiz please go to
www.menti.com
and use the code 61173331
to take part any answers given in the
youtube comments section will not be
counted so please go through the url and
take part in the quiz
okay so time's up
and majority were not able to answer 24
people give the correct answer which is
php remember guys it was asked which
libraries are included not in which
format code is written so either way php
is the correct answer php has web
development features built directly into
the core language the python's add-on
module provides python's web development
capabilities basic cgi capabilities are
provided by the cgi module which comes
as a part of the python standard library
that was a bit tricky the wording was a
bit tricky but the question was easy
okay three people were able to answer
correctly
and murali's second position simba even
he gave the correct answer
and he was the fastest one to answer as
well which makes sense why he has joined
the ninth position okay one third of the
way question 10.
in sql on update cascade ensures which
of the following
is it a normalization
b data integrity
c materialized views
or d all of the above
on update cascade and shows which of the
following
okay time's up
13 people answered all of the above
which is not correct the correct answer
is option b which is data integrity the
cascade option in sql is used along with
the delete and update commands the
cascade is used only when you want your
data to be uniform
for example you might have created a
parent table and a child table inherent
inheriting data from the parent if you
miss using cascade while creating the
tables then the actions performed on
either of the tables will be reflected
on the other one
let us imagine your head office and your
branch has the employee details
after a while an employee resides at
your branch and you need to delete his
records if you did not use the delete
cascade option the head office would
still have his record since the
integrity between the tables is missing
so this is why the cascade option is
used on sql
again the three people from the top 10
were able to answer correctly out of 23
people
and mole is back in second position okay
let's move on to question number 11.
before that let's take a quick reminder
once the quiz ends do not close your
laptops or your phones the top three
scorers that will mention if you are in
first place second place or third place
make sure to take your screenshot and
send the screenshot to youtube contest
at simplylearn.net to receive your
amazon voucher this is just a
verification on our end so that we do
not receive any spam emails hope you
understand and make sure the top three
winners take a screenshot and send it to
us
okay let's move on to question number
11.
in c programming if p equal to tilde
symbol 1 then what is the value of p
is it a 1
b minus 2
c 5
or d minus 1
okay this is very
the fundamentals of c programming
10 more seconds to give your answer 20
people have already answered okay 21
okay
just a couple of more people together
before we reveal the answer
only three people were able to answer
correctly which is -2
see to understand the reasoning behind
this answer we might have to go back to
the bitwise operators in c programming
look at the symbol carefully the tilt
symbol the symbol defines the bitwise
operation that is a complement of a
given number
the ones complement operator which is
the trill symbol sometimes called the
bitwise complement operator yields a bit
wise one's complement of its operand
every bit that is 1 in the operand is 0
in the result
conversely every bit that is 0 in the
operand is 1 in the result
so in the case of minus 2 the 1's
complement of 1 is triple 1 0 which is
equivalent to the 2's complement of 2
that is
minus 2. ranjit has answered this
question the fastest pushing him to
number 4 on the leaderboard
okay let's move on to question number
12. this was a little confusing i get it
in python what is the output for the
following code
a siren if you haven't joined the quiz
go to the url of
www.menti.com and use the code mentioned
on the screen to participate in the quiz
answers given on the youtube comments
chat cannot be calculated really sorry
about that so do join the quiz using the
url and the code
10 more seconds
okay time's up
majority were able to answer correctly
eight people answered of type error see
i guess the people who have answered the
six people you expected to be a but when
you observe closely you have an alphabet
j along with the number one the
combination of one j is considered an
imaginary number so when you include
these numbers into the sort function
python will not be able to compare the
real numbers with the complex numbers
and therefore you will receive a type
error as in this case
okay out of the eight people six of them
were from the top 10 leaderboard
come on guys the people in the second
half of the table
should catch up
in the second half it's only halfway
there so we still have more than half
the questions left
let's see how that lead about changes
okay moving on to question number 13.
in python which of the following
statements is invalid if i'm using a set
as follows and you can see the picture
the options are a minimum s
option b sum of s
option three print s of three
and four is max of s
twenty five seconds to give your answer
which in python
which of the following statements is
invalid it can show error it can be an
exception whichever one of these is
invalid
okay not a lot of people answered this
one
okay
okay but those who answer majority
answered correctly which is eight people
answered which option c is print s of
three so i guess you predicted all the
statements were true for a moment but
when you write out the question again
you see we were all using a set
and in the set we do not have indexing
so in the third option we were trying to
print a value stored in the set by
accessing a specific index value this
statement will be considered invariant
because like you mentioned
there is no indexing while using a set
there might be slight shuffle in the
board
okay now
he's nuts as still
first position locked by a hairpin
let's go to question number 40 and see
if anmol can catch up to the top
in the c programming language which
header file should be included to use
dynamic memory allocation functions
is it a memory.h
is it b stdlib.h
is it c string.h or d
dos.h
20 seconds
quickly the quickly you answer the more
points you get so even if you have a
small hunch go ahead with it there are
30 questions there are plenty of
opportunities to take the lead if you
have a hunch take it
okay so time is up
as expected majority people were able to
answer correctly the people who have
used dynamic memory allocation the
correct answer is stdlib dot h
the standard library header file or the
stdlib.h
is the mandatory header file that is
needed to incorporate the dynamic memory
allocation functions like catalog
function malloc reallock and free in the
c programming language all four others
dynamic memory functions are not
accessible by default as they are used
only in special scenarios that include
dynamic programming paradigms
pretty simple quick question right
okay everyone was able to answer this
question correctly in the top 10
leaderboard
and mould being the fastest again
down by a hairpin okay
let's see what happens in the next set
moving on to question number 15 as we
reach halfway of a quiz
what is the current version of php that
is being used by facebook
is option a php 3.0
is it b h php
is it option c php 4.0
or d php 7.0
15 more seconds
what is the current version of php that
is being used by facebook
i'm assuming you guys all use facebook
you all have migrated to instagram by
now
okay 22 people were able to answer
before time was up
only two people gave the correct answer
it is
hp hp as weird as it may sound hvhp is
not php but a php used by facebook yeah
facebook is not using php by designing
its own php called the hip hop or hp hpi
which is an advanced version of hphp
facebook php code is compiled by the
hip-hop virtual machines it transforms
code into highly optimized c plus plus
and then uses g plus plus to compile it
hip hop executes the source code in a
semantically equivalent manner and
sacrifices some rarely used features
hip-hop includes a core transformer a
re-implementation of php's runtime
system and a rewrite of many common php
executions to take advantage of these
performance optimizations
two people answer answering this
correctly one of them was these nuts as
he solidifies his position
at the top spot
and he was the fastest answer okay
let's move on to question number 16. we
have reached halfway guys
question number 16 is what is the most
common reason to use inheritance
is it option a to use abstraction
is it option b to use in interface
is it to see to use code security
or d to promote code reuse
by the way while you answer these
questions if you are watching the
youtube stream drop down your position
in the chat box it will be helpful to
know who stands for
10 more seconds to give the correct
answer
as expected lot of people were able to
answer this correctly which is option d
to promote code reusability the
inheritance helps to reuse the same code
and saves time
every concept out of the four
object-oriented programming concepts is
built for a specific purpose
for example abstract plays an important
role in hiding the critical logic from
the end user encapsulation binds the
data with their respective methods
polymorphism is used in scenarios that
need method overriding based on the
situation
similarly inheritance is employed to
improvise development speed by using an
existing code and inheriting the
properties in the parent class
majority were able to answer correctly
only three people of the top 10 were not
able to
which might pull them down the rankings
no only simba went down to number 10 the
rest of them more or less had the same
position okay let's see how that shakes
up
and question 17
which of the sql statements will
permanently delete the data
is it option a delete
is it option b drop
is it c truncate or d cascade
we have already covered cascade in one
of the previous questions
so try to recall what we did learn do
not go back on the video try to recall
10 more seconds
okay nine people answer the question
correctly
correct answer being truncate
of course the delete and drop statements
in sql are equally capable of erasing
data from a table but we are looking to
erase the data permanently so this can
be achieved by the truncate option only
in contrast the other options are prone
to recover the erase data
so it's a complete opposite of what we
are aiming to do
there might be a small change in the
lead about yeah it is very small between
the sixth and the seventh places with
nithyaran being the fastest person to
answer question number 17
but let's see what happens with 80.
in sql keywords
dash is used along with wildcards
is it option a not in only
is it option b in and not in
is it option c in only
or option d like and i like only
i'm guessing a lot of people have
forgotten their sql standards based on
how many people are giving the correct
answers for the sql questions
let's see
10 more seconds
but this time 22 people have answered
rather quickly so i'm guessing majority
will be able to give the right option
this time
yeah 12 people were answering the
question correctly see most of the
remaining operators also look like they
can go along with wild cards but let me
remind you wild cards are string
oriented a wildcard character is used to
substitute one or more characters in a
string they are like used with the like
operator the like operator is used in a
where clause to search for a specified
pattern in a column since like and i
like are used for pattern matching
pattern matching revolves around only
string type data i hope that's as clear
as i can make it for you
i think we're going to see a drop in the
leaderboard
and we did morally has slid down to
fourth position with nithya ram taking
the third position
it seems answering the last question the
first is help nichoram move up in the
rankings okay question number 19 which
of the following sql commands can sort
the entire rows of the table
is it a sort by b order by
c group by
or d aligned by
one second even more sql
10 more seconds
which are the following sql commands can
sort the entire rows of a table
okay yeah majority were able to answer
15 people answered order by which is the
right option but those that have
answered sort by end group by as a quick
solution most of you might have
conjured the option to be sort by the
reality is slightly different the order
by keyword sorts the result certain
ascending or descending order if you
forget to inform sql to order the table
in descending order specifically the
order by keyboard sorts the records in
ascending order by default to sort it in
descending order you can just use the
desc keyboard to use with the order by
keyboard
okay a lot of people not able to answer
murray was the fastest one to answer but
he still
is in fourth position by a hairpin while
the first two positions remain unaltered
okay let's move on to our final set of
10 questions which is question number 20
which says in vfs or bread first search
graph traversal which data structure is
employed
is it a stack
b array
c q or d
link list
in red first search graph traversal
which data structure is employed
stack array queue or linked list
people who have worked on java and say
plus plus this is your time to shine
okay we're done with the time
ah the just how eight people have
answered kyle seven have confused with
the stack
see uh going by the book stack is used
in depth first search not bread first
bread for search algorithm traverses a
graph in a bread towards motion and uses
a queue to remember the next vertex to
start a search when a dead end occurs in
any iteration
this can be achieved if you have a first
come first out type of data structure
and q is the only one of that kind
so that's why we prefer to use a queue
instead of attack in bread for search
reversal stack is for depth first
just to reiterate
and there is virtually no change in the
top 10 lead report okay moving on to our
third half of the quiz
question number 21
predict the outcome of the following
snippet of code
this should be relatively easy for
people who have
used coding if you have used arrays when
writing programs
but let's see
the option a is three
option b is zero option c is 1
and option d is 2
40 more seconds
30 more seconds
21 people have answered 22
okay
so i think like three four people have
not yet decided on the output okay three
more seconds
and we are done
the correct answer
majority were able to answer correctly
which is one
see the statement the innermost bracket
or the inner in direction evaluates to
one and the value at index 1 for the
outer indirection
is 1. so the correct answer is option c
1 again
this majority were able to answer
correctly i'm guessing there should not
be a lot of change in the leaderboard
okay just hey is moving on from the
second half of the table to the ninth
position tenth and the last question and
ninth in this one let's see if we can
use the last eight positions to move all
the way up to one
okay question number twenty two what is
the latest text unix version
is it unix system 5
unix version 7
unix air 1.1 or unix square 2.0
what is the latest unix version
for people who dabble in a lot of linux
operating systems this should be fairly
standard
for your domain of work
okay
yeah majority were able to answer which
is unix version 7 which is the latest
version of the certificate standard
units version 7 aligned with the single
unix specification version 4 of the 2018
edition
who was the fastest to answer this
question okay someone not from the top
of the leaderboard okay no animal was
the fastest to give the correct answer
this time okay
let's move on to question number 23
which of the following type of classes
allows only one object of it to be
created
is it a virtual class
is it be abstract class
is it c singleton class or d
friend class
got a very weird feeling about this
because in the first five seconds around
10 people gave the answer
so let's see how accurate
that hunch was
15 more seconds
for the rest of the people to give their
answers
time's up and uh
almost everyone gave the correct answer
which is singleton class
see some c process programmers might
have considered the option of d which is
friend class for the print function as a
random guess but the correct answer is
singleton this question was actually
from java to be honest the term friend
class might have distracted many into c
plus plus singleton is a famous design
pattern in java
it is a design pattern that ensures that
a class can have only one object
to create a singleton class a class must
implement the following properties which
is create a private constructor of the
class to restrict object creation
outside of the body
everyone was able to give the correct
answer this time
so there is no change in the leaderboard
and nithyaram could not move into second
in spite of giving the answer the
fastest
okay let's move on to question number
24.
which of the following is not a type of
constructor
is it a a copy constructor would be
friend constructor
c default constructor or d parameterized
constructor
guys i would just like to remind you the
people who have are occupying the first
second and third position right now do
not close the window once the quiz ends
take a screenshot of your position where
it's clearly states that you have
finished first second or third and send
it to us at youtube contest at
simplylearn.net to receive your vouchers
this is only for the top three winners
okay the 13 people were answered
correctly which is friend constructor
see again in java we have come across
the copy constructor default and
parameterized constructor but there is
nothing
called a friend constructor that was a
pretty easy one come on guys
okay we might see a shuffle in the
leaderboard this time
and we do finally anmol was able to
catch up to ease nuts and has taken the
first position
with a handful of questions to go let's
see if we can hold his own while we
answer the final six questions of this
quiz was going to question about 25 how
many instances of an abstract class can
be created
you can see the options which is either
1 5
13 or 0.
you have a lot of trigger happy
participants because
the moment the question arrives i see at
least 10 15 people just
answer right away
a lot of trigger happy people in this
quiz
how many instances of an abstract class
can be created 10 more seconds
okay
eleven people give the correct answer
which is zero but i'm i'm very surprised
that seven people thought the answer
would be five considering it's a random
number but uh see it's an abstract class
i cannot create an instance of an
abstract class because it does not have
a complete implementation the purpose of
an abstract class is to function as a
base for its subclasses it acts like a
template or an empty or partially empty
structure
and you can extend it and build on it
before you can use it it does not have a
complete in
structure and y0 because abstract class
is a class that is declared using the
keyword abstract but it may or may not
include abstract methods it cannot be
instantized but it can be subclassed
both armhole and merely gave the
question in the first second give the
correct answer in the first second and
retain the first and third positions
handsomely okay last five questions
moving on to question number 26
which of the following is the first
computer virus
okay a bit of cyber security creeping in
now is it option a nem da
is it b creeper
is it c slayer or d tinba
so the first computer virus
okay i don't see a lot of questions
people answering this right away
good to know
10 more seconds
time is up
and uh eight people give the correct
answer which is creeper while majority
of the people actually gave wrong which
is named slayer
no one answered timber which is
surprising but uh yeah the creeper was
the first computer virus and was
completely harmless it was not created
to bring harm to people but it did take
long it did not take long for the idea
of self-replicating software to turn to
the dark side like a virus infects a
human body by replicating versions of
itself to pass it on to other hosts a
computer virus threads by inserting its
code and spreading to new computers via
different networks
the idea of a computer virus was
published in the essay of theory of
self-reproducing automata by john von
neumann in 1949 do give it a read since
it's a very interesting publication
still the first applicating computer
program was not written until 1971.
it was the program was not actively
malicious software as it caused noise
damage to data the only effect being a
message at output to the teletype
reading i am the creeper catch me if you
can which is something similar
that almond will be saying to people
below him since he has
given the correct answer immediately
again and kept his first position okay
let's move on to question number 27
which language is known for writing the
highest number of most powerful and
malicious viruses
is it a d lang
is it b nim
let's see
c programming language or is it the rust
this is a fairly standard programming
language that
is being used in the industry
15 more seconds
okay not a lot of people answered this
one surprisingly
but the ones who did majority were right
the correct answer is the c programming
language see as surprising as it is c is
one of the oldest most powerful and
frankly one of the exotic programming
languages that can either bring the dead
malware back to life or recreate a new
one the other options are also the
languages used to design and deploy
viruses
still none of them outperformed see in
this category as most of the wild
malicious software is written using the
mother of programming languages a big
shout out to c and another good user you
need strong fundamentals of c and
subsequently c plus
we see a small change in the sixth and
seventh position between simba and ranji
but overall there is little fluctuation
on the leaderboard okay final three
questions
question number 28 who owns a who is the
publisher of the ubuntu operating system
is it a ibm
is it be microsoft
c canonical or d
apple
is a publisher of the ubuntu operating
system that is a linux derivative
come on
five more seconds okay a lot of people
have already answered okay great
so
okay 13 people answered correctly which
is canonica so for those unaware
canonical is a british company that
publishes and owns all the variants of
the linux operating and the ubuntu
operating system my mod it's an ubuntu
operating system the members of the
canonical team lead aspects of ubuntu
such as the kernel the default desktop
which is a unity desktop foundations
security openstack and kubernetes
however the governance of ubuntu is
somewhat independent of canonical with
volunteer leaders from all around the
world taking responsibility for many
critical elements of the project
okay there might be a small change on
the leaderboard no
it has the same although dinesh has
taken his position on the 10th position
by being the fastest one to answer
question number 28 but we will move on
to question number 29 now which is
which are the first operating system
so much talk of canonical in ubuntu
let us
tell us which is the first operating
system is it option a dos
is it option b q dos
is it c windows
or d
general motors n a a
the world's first operating system
there is a lot of history when it comes
to computing this is only the beginning
trust me
which is the world's first operating
system
although it does seem a lot of people
know the answer considering how quickly
we got
some answers
okay yeah most of the people were right
which is 12 people answered with general
motors and double a so many know ibm for
manufacturing and selling computers with
an operating system back in the 70s but
general motors actually came up with the
operating system before ibm the first
operating system used for real work was
gm naa naaio produced in 1956 by general
motors research division for its ibm 704
customers also produced most of the
early operating systems for ibm
mainframes directly
so general motors gets the credit for
the world's first operating system
no change in the leaderboard as we move
to her final question question number
30.
let's see if this causes an upset on the
top three leaderboard which operating
system was the first to originate among
the following
was it a windows
or b linux
pretty straightforward question with a
relatively simple answer as well
did windows come first or linux
final question guys
10 more seconds
okay it's
it's as close as could have gotten with
10 people answering windows and 11 going
for linux see most of you
have got confused unix with linux and
guess it might be linux but in reality
windows originated in 1985 while linux
originated in 1991.
unix originated before any other
operating system and it's a different
ball game together but it is not
directly correlated to linux
so with that i believe we have reached
the end of our quiz with the end of 30
questions let's see the leaderboard
somehow
unverl has still managed to keep his
first position even though he was not
able to answer the last question so
congratulations to anmol yeeznutz and
murli for being the top three scorers in
this quiz
please send your screenshots to youtube
contest at the read simplylearn.net to
receive your amazon vouchers
thank you for everyone who took
who took part in this quiz and spend
your time with us we keep having these
quizzes on different technologies every
now and then
please follow us on our social handles
and subscribe to our youtube channel to
stay updated since we
since we have the community post way
before we start the quizzes so you can
stay updated and be there during the
start of the quiz to take part thank you
so much for your time
stay safe
you